the machine wants you compliant they
want you defenseless they want you sick
because then you are a permanent
customer for big Pharma and dependent
sick people aren't self-motivated they
don't believe that they can you know
choose their own path in life and make
it happen and those people also aren't
likely to challenge tyranny or
authoritarianism right because they're
weak right they become weak and weaker
and weaker and when you're sick and you
don't feel well and your medication
depends and you're a great customer for
big Pharma that's fantastic which often
holds the hands with big government as
we saw when it came to the covid-19
vaccine financially
um and also it empowers that big
government structure it empowers you to
get smaller and smaller and weaker and
weaker and them to get bigger and then
you start feeling like you need them
it's all a game it is all a game to make
you weaker and them stronger and that is
how you Empower tyranny